foreign
I have always been attracted to two
things one filming videos I would always
grab the family camera and film these
dramatic stories with my little bitty
toys
and on the other hand my parents were
always making it a priority for me to
learn black history because they knew
that it wasn't going to be a priority in
my school's education so from a very
young age I developed a sense of voice
creativity in my message
I'm Taylor Cassidy I'm a social media
content creator and today I want to
share with you why social media virality
doesn't have the impact that you might
think
so we're going to go over to my high
school years it was 2020 and a new app
just came out called Tick Tock and all
the cool kids were getting on it and I'm
a cool kid so I got on it as well and I
thought this is amazing this is a time
for me to combine the two things that I
absolutely love and put them into one
and so that's exactly what I did
sitting on my bedroom floor
on the first day of Black History Month
I created my first fast black history
video where I talked about a black
figure in 60 seconds or less and I
posted it and it went viral y'all wow it
was my room and uh I mean thousands of
people were looking at this video and
seeing this message and uh I was so
excited because the passion that I had
the passion that I had for black history
people were loving it and spreading it
as well
and so I continued to do it I continued
the fast black history series and along
with other videos I grew my account I
got 200k followers yeah 500k a million
followers what like wow
and when you look at these numbers I
wonder if you think to yourself wow this
girl type of Cassidy is so impressive
and I think y'all thanks so much but uh
I also want to ask you
even though you might look at these
numbers and see like
these millions of people are watching
her she must have a great impact
when they ask you
would you think the same thing if I told
you I only talked to a thousand people a
day
about 500.
what about one
now why do you think about this I'll
take you to February of 2021. and it was
one year after I started my fast black
history series and I thought to myself
man if that many people looked at my
videos last year they're all gonna come
back right I mean probably even more so
who wouldn't want to support this
message and so I pulled out all of the
stops I got a green screen I got
costumes I got an external video maker I
went bougie with it
and I created my first Fastback history
video for 2021 and I posted it
and in the end
I was disappointed
I mean
where did everybody go
there weren't half as many people
watching as there were last year what
was wrong and mind you
there were still thousands of people
watching my videos but that wasn't a
problem
the problem is that my mindset was so
focused on those numbers that I thought
to myself
is millions of people aren't watching my
videos
did my message even really matter that
much in the first place
and because of this a deep insecurity
developed in me
and I started drastically changing my
content to try and adhere to Trends to
try and make it go more viral
and I mean it worked I had many viral
videos after that but
why whenever I looked at my account
I whenever I looked at my own videos
did I not feel fulfilled
and it took this one video
that I posted it was a motivational
video and I I mean I had posted them
before and I still post them they're so
much fun what is this one video
and I filmed it posted it it went viral
600k views yes
but after a while I privated it I took
it down
because whenever you looked into the
comments it was only spam
random emojis and fake accounts
commenting on the post
but not only this
I knew that whenever I looked back at
that video
the pep talk the pep talk sentences that
I was giving
meant nothing to me
they weren't connected to me and I knew
that they were just buzzwords that I was
using for virality
and in the end I didn't feel inspired
I felt sleazy
and that moment took me down a very
important and long journey of
understanding that social media virality
doesn't always mean impact
we had a pandemic all of our social
Avenues were taken away the way that we
use our voice the way that we interact
was completely changed and so we all
flocked to social media and in fact Tick
Tock in particular had an 800 percent
increase in users by August of 2020.
that's crazy that means that it's easier
than ever to have millions of people
listen to what you have to say with a
click of a button
but that notion
that desire for our virality has changed
the way we think about the definition of
impact
who's a gen zero in here raise your hand
let me see y'all hey I see y'all
we grew up with this notion of Fame we
know what instantaneous fam looks like
we know it and I'll prove it to you look
at the TV shows that we used to watch
Shake it up it's about two girls dancing
but they're famous
iCarly it's about a group of friends you
know making funny skits but they're
famous
Hannah Montana oh this one is about just
a regular girl going to school
but she's famous
and because of this I bring this up
because we've grown up believing that
the highest point of achievement
accomplishment and impact
must be a change must be achieved
through Fame right
but that makes it all the more hard for
somebody who doesn't have a big
following
to believe that their voice and their
perspective matter because we've grown
up believing that the bigger the
following
the bigger the impact
but those two things don't add up
rustic talk user to say the math ain't
massive
but what if I told you
that you have the power to change the
world
even if you just impact one person
that's all you have let's get into it
have a clear message and goal and then
stick by it here's an example this is a
journal entry that I wrote the beginning
of my Tick Tock career and I basically
wrote down what tiktok meant to me what
I wanted to do with it and what my goal
was
and in doing this I gave myself a
mission statement so that if I ever got
lost or frustrated or confused I had
something to come back to
and even to this day I come back to this
and I abide by these same themes
now for you what that means is this is
the part where you cement in yourself
that your perspective is needed and that
it matters
and even if somebody else is doing the
same thing that you're doing or talking
about the same message that you want to
talk about
you stay steady and share it anyway
because
your perspective and the way that you
have developed and developed your voice
in this world nobody else has done it
like you have and that is your
superpower
all right we've got our message we're
sticking by it now we need to check
where your resolve is placed
what is resolve resolve is the
characteristic that helps you to keep on
going towards your goal even when there
are inconveniences or discomforts
it's what helps you to watch that one
more Netflix episode even though your
eyes are falling asleep
it's what helps you to keep on doing
your homework Georgetown even when you
don't feel like doing it it's what keeps
you going
and I say check where your resolve is
placed because in sharing your message
or goal it is so easy to fall into
putting it into seeing how many people
you can get in front of you seeing how
many people you can reach
and in doing that you sacrifice your
message and exploit it for fame and
popularity
instead
place your resolve in knowing that you
have the very ability to impact one
person and change their life because you
have the ability to change the world
but you also have the ability to impact
one person who has the ability to change
the world as well
and that is still so cool
okay you may be thinking Taylor all
right I've got my message I'm sticking
by it I know where my resolve is placed
so why in the world whenever I post a
video on Instagram it doesn't even get
10 likes
why is that
and I'll tell you even though there
might not be millions of people looking
at your video
you really don't know who is going to
stop on it and truly take to heart the
words that you have to say
and that brings me to my last point
focus on the impact of one see my
transition yeah
I'll give you more examples you know
I'll come with the receipts uh use
comments are from videos that
posted where somebody was inspired by
them or inspired by my account to go out
and make a change in their own life and
one of them even says that they are
going into their school and campaigning
for more black history to be taught the
very message that I wanted to share in
the first place
and I show you these specific comments
because every single one of them came
from videos that a lot of people
consider flopped did not go viral
unsuccessful failed
but that goes to show that the videos
that I posted weren't defined by the
millions of people that did or didn't
look at them
they were defined by the very ability
that they had to reach out and impact to
one person to go and change their entire
community
and that is so much more valuable and
sustaining than creating something or
sharing something just for the purpose
of getting quick virality
all right we've got our message we've
got our understanding that the
individual impact is just as important
as reaching a thousand
so why is it so hard for us to share our
perspective in our voice how is it so
hard for us to get over that fear
I'll tell you one more story before I go
whenever I was in high school I entered
a short film competition where I made a
short film about a young black girl
going through school and finding her own
identity as a black woman in the midst
of stereotypes being pushed on her by
her peers and her classmates
and in doing this I was so scared
because it was
a story that I had went through it was a
very personal story of mine but I pushed
on anyway here are some stills from the
film oh my gosh Taylor Cassidy is just
like Issa Ray wow thank y'all I
appreciate it
but I was so scared to make this film
but I pushed on anyway
and at the film festival whenever they
were showing all the competitors films
afterwards a girl came up to me
and basically said to me how much she
related with the main character
how much she understood what the main
character went through
and she thanked me for making something
that connected with her and helped her
to feel seen
and in that moment
understood something very very important
if I had let my fear of embarrassment my
fear of failure
or my fear of lack of a reaction from
people stopped me from spreading this
message I would have never been able to
give someone the permission to let go of
their own fear
for you
what that means is that the passion the
urgency and the love that you have for
your idea and your message must be
greater than your fear
and notice how I said greater than
and not the fear will be non-existent
because the very fact that fear and
anxiety is associated with your message
is proof that it has the power to change
everything
so
as you go on into your life maybe you'll
go into business maybe you'll go into
art maybe you'll come up maybe you'll
become a twitch streamer I don't know
they make a lot of good money
remember to keep steady in your message
protect your voice from being distorted
by gaining popularity and fame
in understand and focus the individual
impact of one
know that your perspective the way that
you act and interact in this world is
the key to changing it
I believe in you
keep Rising
thank you so much